devenir tétraplégique perdre l'usage de
ces quatre membres est une des pires
choses qui puisse se produire mais la
médecine progresse une nouvelle
opération permet d'améliorer la qualité
de vie de certaines personnes atteintes
de ce type de paralysie voici l'histoire
de Jeanne
[Musique]
on a vraiment cru que mon art est arrivé
je me suis cassé le cou
[Musique]
je suis encore vivante mais ma vie a
complètement changé
[Musique]
depuis le 15 décembre 2021 je suis
peut-être aplégique je n'ai plus de
sensations de la poitrine jusqu'aux
orteils
j'ai perdu beaucoup de choses dont ma
liberté de mouvement
malgré ça je reste forte mais je
m'appelle Jeanne carrière aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous raconter mon histoire
je scénariste en cinéma et pour moi la
création est un mode de vie l'écriture
c'est ma façon de m'évader j'aimerais
encore taper sur les touches de mon
clavier comme avant l'accident même si
mes bras bougent quand même très bien
mais mes doigts sont que du spaghettis
en ce moment j'écris avec des pointeurs
des comme des petits crayons que je
touche mon clavier d'ordinateur sinon je
suis capable de écrire avec mes
jointures mais c'est pas précis il y a
aussi du positif j'ai rencontré la
docteur Tremblay Dominique Tremblay
cette rencontre a été marquante parce
qu'elle m'a proposé quelque chose
d'incroyable
[Musique]
la docteur Tremblay m'offre de me
redonner l'usage de mes mains
elle va transférer des nerfs mes propres
nerfs pour réanimer les muscles de mes
mains
c'est vraiment ça le sport c'est de
changer de
terminologie de dire j'ai l'usage de mes
bras je suis plus un tétraplégique je
suis un paraplégique ça me donne les
frissons en parler mais c'est un peu ça
qu'on l'espoir qu'on veut leur offrir
lorsque j'ai appris qu'il y avait de
l'espoir pour moi d'avoir cette
opération là c'est
un mélange d'émotion mais la seule
émotion j'ai pas eu c'est la peur parce
que c'est un très grand soulagement sans
leur demande qu'est-ce qui aimerait le
plus améliorer au quotidien c'est
vraiment la fonction de leurs mains pour
leur permettre d'être plus indépendant
essentiellement
l'objectif premier pour moi de
l'opération c'est pouvoir continuer mon
métier c'est une manière d'évasion et
une très grande source de bonheur
[Musique]
ce matin je suis arrivée à l'hôpital à 6
heures je suis pas nerveuse je suis
plutôt excitée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va être une longue journée mon
opération va durer
pour avoir un bon muscle favorable un
bon air les nerfs essentiellement c'est
les câbles électriques au niveau du
corps qui fait la connexion entre le
cerveau et les différentes parties de
notre corps dont les muscles l'influx
nerveux essentiellement c'est comme le
courant électrique c'est on va changer
le circuit d'influx nerveux vers un qui
fonctionne à un qui ne fonctionne pas
puis là en refaisant la connexion avec
le temps tout ça va se régénérer et
refonctionner deux équipes de
chirurgiens travaillent en même temps
qu'on a commencé à avoir notre mère on
est content
une sur chaque bras
pour bien comprendre ce qui va se passer
la docteur tremblait me l'a expliqué
simplement on isole le nerf saint on le
coupe on le transpose vers le nerf
inactif on le connecte
l'influx nerveux circulent à nouveau le
muscle bouge
la docteur tremblait dit qu'on ne peut
pas transférer n'importe quelle marque
il y a plein de détails à vérifier pour
choisir le bon
ça c'est le poignet qui fait de
l'extension
on va faire quelques points on lave un
peu pour me la colle on répète ce qu'on
va faire ça
c'est sûr qu'on emprunte d'ailleurs et
quand on fait cette emprunt c'est super
important de pas enlever de la fonction
de d'un autre endroit on va s'assurer
que toujours au minimum deux muscles qui
font la même fonction l'exemple
classique c'est la flexion du coude j'ai
plus qu'un euse qui font la flexion du
coude donc je peux aller emprunter un
des nerfs qui va un de ces muscles sans
que ça l'a fait que la capacité de faire
la flexion du coude c'est pas simple
d'isaler le bonheur pour y arriver elle
utilise un instrument spécial toujours
le moment stressant de choisir la bonne
branche pour donner une meilleure
mouvement une fois qu'on est identifié
le nerf on a un stimulateur nerveux qui
va amener un influx extérieur on va le
mettre sur le nappe puis là on va
pouvoir visualiser le même mouvement
qu'on a vu à vrai dire lors de
l'évaluation c'est ça qu'on va
rechercher
[Musique]
après mon accident j'ai dû passer deux
mois au soin de
puis je consacre 110% de mes énergies à
ma réadaptation
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'espoir de devenir une
berceuse du piano loin de là mais c'est
comme les petites frustrations de pas
avoir des mains qui fonctionnent si on
est capable d'enlever une coupe de
frustration puis de ce que c'est
difficile
d'avoir à utiliser les dents
[Musique]
comme tu vois là
c'est le fun dans ma future ville de
tête
obligée d'avoir les les clous à mes
attentes ou le mieux tenir la pomme sans
chinois de
[Musique]
la docteur tremblait ses collègues au
parle depuis 6 ans
je sais qu'après l'opération mais même
sont pas comme avant je suis réaliste
on va faire les transferts nerveux pour
améliorer la force mais on va aussi
faire des transferts tendineux pour
avoir vraiment une pince plus forte
qu'on est comme dans la lésion fait que
le plus vite qu'on fait se transfert le
meilleur résultat que va avoir les trois
mouvements qu'on espère redonner à
Jeanne c'est l'extension poignet droit
pousse vous voyez le pouce puis les
doigts
c'est que ça va donner ça puis on va
aller chercher ça
c'est presque terminé avec ses doigts de
fil le docteur Tremblay reconnecte les
nerfs ça s'est bien déroulé maintenant
je dois être patient ici c'est celui qui
est connecté comme il faut au cerveau
qui va amener du bon courant pour
pouvoir faire fonctionner les muscles
une fois la connexion faite il y a une
période juste de guérison puis ensuite
il y a la régénérescence c'est ça qui
prend du temps puis c'est pour ça que
les transferts nerveux le résultat est
pas immédiat
[Musique]
personne ne dit que l'opération serait
miraculeuse on pense pas que je pourrais
écrire avec les 10 doigts mais peut-être
avec deux doigts beaucoup plus précis
suite à un rétablissement d'au moins 8
semaines je vais devoir
faire une réhabilitation de moins deux
ans
si la réadaptation est longue c'est que
je dois réapprendre l'usage de mes mains
et c'est pas si simple au début le
cerveau est encore habitué de passer par
l'ancien circuit du coup à petit coup
faut qu'on lui apprenne que c'est pas ça
son circuit il faut l'amener vers un
autre circuit mais l'objectif c'est que
ça soit pas un effort quotidien d'avoir
à penser comment faire fonctionner tel
muse pour faire tel mouvement au Québec
on est seulement 9 patients à avoir subi
cette opération
je me trouve privilégiée puis d'une
certaine façon
chanceuse aussi
est-ce que tout le monde est un bon
candidat non la réponse c'est non l'âge
est un peu un limitant parce qu'on sait
que la régénérescence se fait mieux
quand on est plus jeune puis des fois on
a des candidats qui ont
malheureusement une maison trop haute et
nous manque des bons muscles à pouvoir
dire j'en prends de lui pour redonner
ailleurs
[Musique]
mon père et moi en train de cuisiner qui
aurait dit il y a du beau partout même
dans le malheur c'est incroyable
j'ai juste que ma parade ici soit la
moins par exemple possible et je trouve
que j'y arrive toujours un jour
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
les mots se bousculent encore dans ma
tête je tape moins vite mais au moins je
tape avec les doigts comme avant
[Musique]